I received the really interesting email from
Russell this week who said it would be interesting
to discuss that Donald Trump appears
to be the first truly atheist president of
the United States, but for whatever reason
it's not really being discussed. And maybe
just as importantly the evangelical right
wing Christians still voted for Donald Trump
over Hillary Clinton. And this is a really
interesting topic because there's a few different
angles to it. First of all, Trump does appear
to be at minimum, completely nonreligious
in the sort of dogmatic belief sense, if not
an out and out atheist, but it's just not
been part of the narrative around Donald Trump.
And I would argue that the reason it's not
been part of the narrative is because it's
wholly irrelevant to Donald Trump's governance.
And also because Donald Trump took the correct
position on abortion for those who vote based
on religion, that is all that matters. Trump's
personal religiosity, much like Trump's personal
history with women, much like Trump's personal
history with all sorts of other stuff that
you wouldn't think would appeal to the evangelical
vote, does not matter as long as Donald Trump
takes what they believe to be the correct
position on the issue of abortion.
So let's first go through the case for believing
that Donald Trump has an atheist or agnostic
or nonreligious. Number one, there's really
been no mention of Donald Trump's holiday
plans when it comes to church services around
Christmas or whatever other holiday. There's
no mentions of Donald Trump's use of the White
House Chapel or the Camp David Chapel. I mean,
we just never hear about any of it whatsoever.
Number two, there've been no references to
Trump's church membership in New York City
throughout his entire life, other than I believe
it was in South Carolina during the campaign.
Trump said that he's a presbytarian Protestant
and that he goes to marble collegiate church
as often as he can, which seemed like a lie,
especially since marble collegiate church
in Manhattan is reformed, not presbytarian.
And most people who go to a church regularly
and are religious know what the religious
denomination is of the church that they're
going to.
It'd be sort of weird not to know your own
religion. That's strange. The church also
said that Donald Trump is not an active member
of that church. So that just seemed like a
pandering lie. George W. Bush, George H W
bushes funeral. You might recall that Donald
Trump clearly didn't know the religious songs
and the prayers or whatever it was that was
being sung. He, uh, the other presidents,
W and their significant others were singing
those songs confidently and, uh, Donald Trump
had clue what was going on. Now that could
be just Trump's general ignorance. It could
be his lack of reading ability, which we've
talked about. But coincidentally, it's religious
stuff that Donald Trump seems to be clueless
about. When he was asked about Bible verses,
he claimed that the Bible was one of his favorite
books along with the art of the deal. But
when he was asked again, well, what's one
of your favorite verses?
He says, I wouldn't want to get into it because
it's very personal. Uh, and I don't really
want to get into specific bible verses. But
then in a different moment, he had his infamous
two Corinthians moments that made absolutely
no sense. And people who know about Corinthians
said, two Corinthians is not the way anybody
who is actually familiar with religious texts
would cite it. So, uh, it's actually unclear
only because of Trump's ignorance. Right?
On the one hand, Trump might just be ignorant
about religion in the same sense that he's
ignorant about so many other things without
actually being an atheist or a nonbeliever.
On the other hand, if this, or any other person
who exhibited the characteristics I've just
told you, we would say, oh yeah, that's absolutely
an atheist. Now interestingly, even if Trump
is an atheist, it doesn't really seem that
he would be the first atheist president.
There are a number of presidents that are
believed to have been atheist. Even if they
didn't say it publicly in those words, which
at times passed in the United States would
have been particularly problematic. So you
have Thomas Jefferson. Jefferson was accused
of being an atheist as a campaign strategy
by his opponents, but it's likely that he
was a deist and a free thinker. So not an
atheist per say, but very nonreligious relative
to the sort of cultural and religious climate
of the time. Uh, Abraham Lincoln, people around
Lincoln, including William Herndon, said that
Lincoln's religious views were complicated
and that at times he was an atheist and that
Lincoln was really a follower of Darwin, not
of religion, although publicly Lincoln still
did pay lip service to being a religious person.
Uh, you have Ulysses s grant, not affiliated
with any church, considered to be a Methodist,
but never baptized.
Went to church, rarely reportedly, only did
it to appease his wife who was religious and
in his death note to his wife, he mentioned
meeting her in another world, which suggests
at least some belief in an afterlife, but
significant speculation that he was not a
religious man. Um, and then you have William
Howard Taft. William Howard Taft was described
as a unitarian, often sort of like what we
would call nonreligious Christianity or hipster
Christianity or less religious Christianity,
Christian atheism, so to speak. Once a Taft
said, I believe in God, I do not believe in
the divinity of Christ. So sort of judge it
for the times and evaluate as you will. But
the bottom line here is number one, most importantly,
Donald Trump is still a terrible president,
whether he's religious or not. Number two,
Donald Trump still panders to religious groups
recognizing that they are a predominantly
important, significantly important voting
block.
If you are running as a Republican, a, he
still has opening prayers at events. He participated
in the antiabortion march, March for life,
I believe it's called claiming. I don't know
if we believe it, but he claims to have had
an awakening relatively late in his life,
uh, well into adulthood about, um, uh, a kid
that was born after the mother thought about
having an abortion but didn't. And that that
changed him from being a lifelong pro choice
individual to being anti-abortion. Coincidentally
very shortly before deciding to run for president.
So this is why it's functionally irrelevant
whether Trump's deeply held beliefs are religious
or not. This is similar to what I said earlier
in the week. People say, well, we don't know
if deep down Trump is is a racist. We don't
know if deep down Trump is in a phobic. His
public presence as president of the United
States as commander in chief of the United
States, uh, is a presence that is both racist
and xenophobic.
He is functionally racist and xenophobic.
He is coalescing racists and xenophobes around
his nationalist ideology and his campaign
ideas and all of the rhetoric that he's espousing.
So does it matter deep down whether Trump
is actually racist in his heart of hearts,
in his mind of minds? No, it doesn't matter.
And similarly I would make the case that,
yeah, I do believe that Donald Trump partially
just out of complete and total ignorance of
religion and partially because religion has
never been important to them is probably a
nonbeliever. He is probably at minimum at
agnostic if I had to guess deep down, but
it doesn't really matter because publicly
he is functionally pandering to the religious
right in basically the same way that most
Republican candidates and presidents and elected
officials in the House and Senate have done.
And it makes the question of his deep down
sincerely held religious beliefs, uh, practically
irrelevant from the point of view of governance
and from the point of view of what it is that
he is going to signify to evangelicals when
he says I'm against abortion despite the fact
that he's had the sexual assault allegations
and uh, alleged rape of his ex wife, uh, and
the affairs and the videos with Jeffrey Epstein
touching women on the rear end does not clear
that that's what they want.
It doesn't really matter because he's functionally
taken the correct position on the most important
religious voting issue. And that is the issue
of abortion. If you disagree with me that
Trump is likely not religious, let me know.
I am on Twitter at d pacman. If you disagree
with me that his sincerely held beliefs actually
do matter as much as or more than the public
representation, uh, on issues of importance
to religion, then let me know. Basically if
you disagree with anything in my analysis,
I'd like to hear from you. I'm on Twitter
at d pacman. The show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show. We're going to open the phone
lines shortly. We are going to answer audience
questions and a lot of very relevant and important
topics to be discussed on today's show.